ladies and gentlemen we are back with
Katie Holmes and her BFF actress Lucy
prayer and Katie thinks she'd make a
good food printing so we want to put our
skills to the test with some unique
spins on her favorite food do you know
what Katie's favorite food is I found
out I'm excited about this nachos I mean
[Applause]
love nachos I'm so excited Lucy did you
are you a nacho fan too yeah absolutely
okay well our waiter and uh who's going
to take care of us today is none other
than Rossi Rossman
hi everybody thank you so much welcome
to Drew's House of nachos
um are you hungry very starving okay
great you want to see what we have first
for you yes okay ready uh up for your
first course we have a fresh Italian
pasta toss in a rich Bolognese topped
with Parmesan fresh basil and ricotta
served on a bread of crispy tortilla
chips it's AKA spaghetti with a meat
sauce and nachos okay
uh
you'll notice this is nacho normal nacho
I know I'm like real I really I really
want a good one me too get a good one
that's I guess that's part of the point
with nachos is like the the spoon the
dip what's your review we wanted to
nurture you like you've never been
nachoed before
that's not easy
um oh
God it's really glim like I don't like
it I like it
I think there's a lot happening yeah
thank you that's a nice way to say yeah
um
Katie
can I take these home you can take those
home yeah I'll keep them warm for you
how do you think that I am as a food
grade
well I'm so sorry
um I think you're smart
I think the masses would not like that
I'll tell you what's going on there's
some like goats or sheep something in
there does anyone taste like that I
didn't do anything
a little cheese on top I hate it okay
I'm so sorry I couldn't do it Lucy what
did you think of the nacho well I mean
the spaghetti definitely wasn't Al Dente
so the soft with the crunchy was nice I
guess yes I liked everything kind of
like put a positive spinner I didn't
like it sorry okay
I'm team Drew okay so you didn't like
the first one what about our second
nacho you ready it is chopped crab with
sushi rice and a delicate drizzle of
spicy mayo top of Julian cucumbers
avocado and a nice little seasoning on
there
um this one I'm gonna swallow no matter
what it takes all right all right ready
okay can we get a close-up of our bowels
as well oh yeah please please zoom on in
I need honest reviews Lucy
is she
good I kind of like it the spicy mayo is
good okay yeah sorry but good question
fishy but good okay what do you think
yeah it stayed in my mouth
all right
it tastes like a poke Bowl on a chip to
me oh that's fun okay I'm gonna take
that as a compliment thank you Katie
Holmes that's all right
[Applause]
uh ready for nacho number three we have
uh Rich vanilla chocolate and strawberry
ice cream chocolate strawberry sauce
whipped creams bananas maraschino
cherries and the light dusting of
colorful Confections served on a bed of
waffle cone chips oh my this to me says
here right yeah this is no yeah this is
like Banana Splits my girlfriend Edition
just load her up oh take that ma'am
thank you so much thank you sir so much
this is one beautifully uh uh appointed
establishment thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what do we think Lucy
10 out of town
I'm gonna get a promotion Michelin star
Drew what do you think
I'm having a revelation
but I want to hear from the food critic
okay it's with the crab I
I think it's a great combo I love the
banana
I I love the chocolate ice cream like I
I'm gonna live here for a minute
it's really good well I want to thank
you and I want to remind you to please
tip your server thank you so much
[Applause]
for Katie's movie where objects and
Lucy's movie paint because they're both
in theaters now
we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign